الهجمات على الروسيه خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه اظهرت ضعف الدفاعات الروسيه بحسب
تقرير
الصحيفه قالت ان التوغلات التي تقوم بها
مجموعات روسيه معارضه اضافه للقصف المتقطع
على الاقليم قد شكل اختبارا لدفاعات الروس
قبل الهجوم المضاد المرتقب العمليات
الاخيره في باجرود دفعت موسكو الى استخدام
قوتها الجويه ومدفعيتها كما انها تزيد
الضغط على الاخيره لسحب بعض قواتها بعيدا
عن الخطوط الاماميه للقتال شرق اوكرانيا
قالت ان تركيز اوكرانيا على استهداف
المناطق الحدوديه قد يضعف بشكل ما دفعات
موسكو في اجزاء من خط المواجهه البالغ
طوله قرابه الفي كم رغم التحصينات
الدفاعيه التي وضعتها روسيا خلال الاشهر
الاخيره على الارض كشف فيلق المتطوعين
الروس وهو احد المجموعات المسلحه المعارضه
عن اسر جنديين روسيين وعرضت هذه المجموعه
اطلاق سراحهم مقابل اسرار اوكرانيا في
السياق اعلن يفجين بريجوجن مؤسس مجموعه
فاجنر التي قادت عمليه السيطره الروسيه
على باخموت انه مستعد لارسال قوات لانقاذ
الاسيررين بدوره اقترح الرئيس الشيشاني
رمضان قادروف اليوم ارسال عناصر من قواته
الى القضاء على المجموعات المسلحه الروسيه
او الاوكرانيه هناك الروسيه المعارضه
الدفاعات الروسيه بمختلف المناطق هدف
لموسكو ونذكر هنا ان الرئيس الذي كان قد
دعى الاسبوع الماضي ونذكر بذلك ايضا
لتحسين الدفاع الجوي في العاصمه بعد تعرض
موسكو لهجمات بطائره مسيره ثلاثاء الماضي
ميدانيا تعمل كل من كييف وموسكو على تكثيف
الهجمات بالصواريخ والمسيرات في محاوله
لاستنزاف الدفاعات الجويه للطرف الاخر
وابعاد القوات عن الخطوط الاماميه فيما كل
هذا ياتي مع ترقب مابات يوصف كما قلنا
بالهجوم المضاد الذي قال الرئيس الاوكراني
برضو مرزالينسكي ان بلاده مستعده لشنه
لكنه اشار الى ان الهجوم سيستغرق بعض
الوقت وستكون تكلفته باهظه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات